identificados tras 38 años los cuerpos
de 34 personas que fueron asesinadas en
la lucha entre el estado peruano y la
guerrilla sendero luminoso entre los
años 1980 y 2000 trabajado como dije
durante dos años en la búsqueda en la
recuperación el análisis identificación
por métodos
odontológicos antropológicos y de
adentro el comité Internacional de la
Cruz Roja dijo que entre los cuerpos
encontrados están los de una familia
completa cuatro niños y sus padres los
restos fueron hallados en diferentes
puntos del departamento de ayacucho El
más afectado por la violencia en la
época de sendero luminoso la fiscalía
dice que la búsqueda continúa en 4000
fosas clandestinas en las zonas de
conflicto compromiso de su sistema es
seguir en la búsqueda de la persona
desaparecidas
realizar la identificación genética que
corresponda y hacer una entrega digna a
las víctimas los restos óseos fueron
entregados a los familiares en pequeños
ataúdes de color blanco en una ceremonia
que se llevó a cabo en la catedral de
mucho Ana Quispe recuerda cuando tenía 8
años despertó en medio de la noche y vio
a sus familiares muertos bien bastante
mejor
como cualquiera ahora van a tener un
velorio este normal como debe ser así va
a ser doctor la mayoría de las víctimas
eran campesinos que hayan sido
declarados como desaparecidos sus
familias pasaron décadas reclamando
justicia en mayo de este año los restos
de 42 víctimas fueron sepultados tras 37
años el enfrentamiento entre el estado y
la guerrilla dejó unos 70.000 muertos y
21.000 desaparecidos el 40% de ellos en
la región de